hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña leonor
sala batán ella fue designada por el
presidente de colombia gustavo petro
como la nueva embajadora de colombia
ante la organización de naciones unidas
estamos ante una histórica lidereza
indígena de colombia una mujer que ha
luchado prácticamente toda su vida por
defender los derechos de los pueblos
originarios de colombia leonor
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24 en español muchísimas gracias
re embajada de francia al canal
de este país y también a ustedes ya la
gran audiencia que tenemos gracias a
usted una vez más bueno como defensora
de los derechos humanos como decíamos
una incansable defensora protectora de
los derechos de los pueblos originarios
de colombia también de la naturaleza de
la tierra y de la paz cómo encarará la
cual serán sus prioridades en leonor en
este nuevo desafío como embajadora de
colombia ante la onu bueno ante todo
quiero destacar que los colombianos
hayamos procurado cambiar 200 años de
vida republicana
en donde los pueblos indígenas y todo
aquello diverso como es la población
étnica jamás hubiéramos tenido
representación en la toma de decisiones
importantes para el país
y creo que esto nos conduce a aceptar
realmente unas políticas
de los pueblos indígenas como es
conservar y cuidar la naturaleza
como es realmente la paz en nuestros
territorios que son compatibles con las
políticas del presidente actual gustavo
petro hablaba usted del cuidado a la
naturaleza un tema clave en lo que ha
sido su liderazgo su activismo ahora
quisiera plantear una situación no
porque bueno los pueblos indígenas de
colombia y del mundo a lo largo de todo
el mundo no se existen gracias a la
resistencia verdad a la lucha desde la
han sobrevivido digamos desde la época
de la conquista gracias a esa
persistente lucha a esa resistencia y
gracias a eso también han atravesado
muchísimos contextos varias épocas
plagadas de muchísimos obstáculos ahora
quisiera preguntarle cómo va a ser
trasladar esa lucha esa resistencia a un
escenario que quizás en algunos puntos
puede resultar hostil verdad me refiero
en las naciones unidas- habrá muchas
posturas vinculadas a modelos de
producción de países de desarrollo
modelos desarrollistas que quizás van en
contra e incluso dañan afectan mucho lo
que es la conservación de la naturaleza
como modo de vida no tiene que ser una
visión más de explotarla
efectivamente es el diálogo entre países
en la humanidad es un tema fundamental y
lo que queda claro es que en este
momento de pandemias en este momento de
cambio climáticos de recalentamiento
global también se ha reconocido que los
pueblos indígenas conservamos la tierra
por lo menos nuestros territorios en
colombia
atesoramos la más extensa diversidad de
biológica que tenemos y somos
reconocidos para eso tenemos una
constitución política en donde nosotros
participamos en donde nuestros
constituyentes lograron
posicionar e incluir orgánicamente los
pueblos indígenas en colombia yo creo
que eso es fundamental
y creo que lo debes saber el mundo no
debe saber
los sistemas de gobierno en muchas
partes y creo que podemos avanzar con la
solidaridad de la comunidad
internacional
hablaba usted de la temática de los
territorios verdad en un país
multicultural como colombia hay muchos
otros de la región hay una problemática
clave que atraviesa a los pueblos
indígenas que tiene que ver con los
desplazamientos de sus territorios
verdad esto ocurre en muchísimos pueblos
originarios de toda la región su
presencia en la onu les va a los va a
empoderar para poder continuar luchando
por sus tierras ancestrales por sus
derechos sobre estas tierras a ver la
paz de los pueblos indígenas no está no
está garantizada por la resistencia
solamente yo creo que lo que nos hace
posible la permanencia como pueblos
indígenas es por la cultura que llevamos
es por la filosofía que practicamos es
por la forma de convivir con la
naturaleza y convivir entre nosotros y
yo creo que son valores son importantes
para la humanidad y la humanidad está
viendo en este momento la necesidad
de un padre más recalentamiento global
que va muy rápido creo y estoy
convencida que la humanidad no tiene a
dónde más ir si destruimos la tierra en
un momento que se destruye a la tierra
nos estamos destruyendo a nosotros
mismos y eso ya elemental elemental para
muchas partes y creo que no es gratuito
que el mundo en organismos tan
importantes como el interamericano
organismos como naciones unidas que dan
cuenta hoy en día de la importancia de
la conservación de la tierra
y bueno estamos dispuestos los pueblos
indígenas como hemos estado siempre a
contribuir realmente
en estado un espacio de igualdad a ser
posible realmente una vida más tranquila
como en colombia en paz buscar la paz y
la paz tiene que ver con el respeto a la
naturaleza y es una necesidad no
solamente colombia la humanidad necesita
realmente hacer un pare para poder mirar
como los objetivos de desarrollo del
milenio son parte fundamental de su
implementación en los países que aún
podemos contribuir le al mundo ahora
quisiera preguntarle cómo fue recibido
su nombramiento entre los integrantes de
la comunidad puedo dialogar con ellos le
trasladaron inquietudes cuestiones
bueno a ver mi reacción frente a la
designación del presidente de la
república a través de sus mecanismos
fue una cuestión muy jovial fue amable
fue de mucha confianza
y bueno de parte mía también fue un poco
dentro de las costumbres que tenemos en
colombia un poco picarescas un poco y
tenemos un mensaje del presidente pero
el presidente ha dicho que no le puede
decir que no y entonces pero como me
pueda dar un mensaje en donde yo acepte
un mensaje que que no pero yo entendía
que era la forma de relacionamiento en
confianza propia nosotros los
colombianos
y fue algo que no lo esperaba no lo
buscaba pero tampoco me sorprendió
cuando quería una designación de este
nivel para pueblos indígenas yo nunca lo
interpreté como una designación personal
intransferible tampoco pensé en la
aceptación que como pueblos indígenas
tenemos que asumirla y asumirla como
parte del liderazgo de colombia y fue
viene y las comunidades han expresado su
satisfacción sus agradecimientos al
presidente de la república
y la verdad es que escenarios
internacionales la aceptación acción
plena que el gobierno esté dando
participación política en la toma de
decisiones en el próximo gobierno es que
bueno como ustedes bien lo decía es un
escenario internacional clave para
muchísimos aspectos para muchísimos
factores que rigen lo que está
ocurriendo a nivel geopolítico en el
mundo de hecho uno de los flagelos que
vive colombia tiene que ver con el
asesinato de la persecución a líderes
indígenas y también líderes sociales y
hablando de este escenario tan visible
que es la onu cómo lograr el apoyo de
otros países del mundo no que los ojos
de los otros países se posen sobre
colombia para poder ayudar a superar
este conflicto la verdad es que en
colombia yo creo que la sociedad civil
tenemos siempre identificados muchos
países que realmente han han hecho el
acompañamiento internacional a los
colombianos tenemos muy claro que ha
sido
importante ese acompañamiento en temas
de antes del conflicto armado con el
conflicto armado y en un proceso que
queremos pacificar el país la comunidad
internacional ha sido clave en la
implementación de los acuerdos de paz y
para mí lo fundamental para colombia es
buscar la implementación de los acuerdos
de paz y en los perfeccionando si es
posible y creo que la disposición de
muchas partes del mundo son muy claras
para el país ahora quisiera tocar otro
punto que también tiene que ver con esto
no debe designar líderes indígenas en
muchísimos puestos de hecho petro ha
nombrado a otras personas que provienen
de pueblos originarios a cargo de varias
funciones no en su en su para su mandato
y quisiera tocar un punto también clave
en este sentido que tiene que ver con la
lengua materna verdad son fundamentales
para transmitir muchísimas cosas que de
otra manera sería imposible transmitir
las va a utilizar también este escenario
que como decíamos es sumamente visible a
nivel internacional y político para
defender los derechos de las lenguas
ancestrales para conservarlas
naciones unidas-
dentro de su estructura de desarrollo
político y social
tiene ya por ejemplo el primero fue el
año internacional de los pueblos
indígenas después tuvo el decenio de los
pueblos indígenas tenemos una
declaración de derechos de los pueblos
indígenas tenemos el foro permanente de
derechos indígenas ahora la unesco
tiene el decenio de las lenguas
indígenas y quiero decir con esto que ha
sido una preocupación permanente ha sido
una decisión de naciones unidas
acompañar a los pueblos indígenas en
este país y yo sigo creyendo que esto es
posible incluso fortalecer esas
decisiones siguen siendo en colombia los
pueblos indígenas hablan 64 idiomas
reconocidos por la constitución y son
son lenguas oficiales en nuestros
territorios
y también tenemos el rezar el palenquero
y el castellano y podemos sumar
67-68 lengua con los otros entonces la
riqueza de la diversidad lingüística en
colombia es supremamente importante para
la humanidad porque este país muy a
pesar de la guerra
creo que esa visión que nos da al que la
transmitimos a través de las lenguas es
una forma de vida que tenemos allí y que
realmente lo que hace lo que hace el
país es tener una diversidad muy amplia
y creo que a la humanidad le conviene
que no vivamos iguales sino que seamos
diversos leonor nos queda poco tiempo
pero no quiero dejar de realizar la
siguiente pregunta que tiene que ver con
preguntas o cuestionamientos a los que
usted misma se ha tenido que ver
expuesta durante todo este proceso como
por ejemplo si habla un inglés para un
organismo que precisamente se
característica por poder hablar
cualquier tipo de lenguaje sin ningún
preguntas que le hicieron que no les
hicieron mejor dicho a otros
funcionarios que ocupan ese mismo cargo
cree que esta designación suya ha dejado
en expuesto en manifestación mejor dicho
cierto racismo por algún sector de la
sociedad o simplemente ignorancia
desinformación a ver yo creo que el
racismo en colombia y es cierto hay
discriminación racial pero yo creo que
la colombia ha venido superando ese
racismo a través de la academia a través
de la forma de la educación de la
población colombiana
sin embargo por ejemplo este tipo de
preguntas cuando la periodista me lo
hizo lo que yo pensaba es será que no
debes saber que naciones unidas tiene un
sistema de lenguas comerciales incluidos
el español y la verdad es que yo he
estado en diferentes países del mundo
unos 35 países que he tenido oportunidad
de visitarlo por alguna razón
el
castellano es lo que yo hablo no no
estado por debajo para poder
relacionarme con otros países y con otra
gente leonor se levanten muchísimas
gracias ha sido un placer su presencia
en entrevista de france 24 en español
muchísimas gracias muchísimas gracias a
usted ya todos a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a que sigan
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y también por supuesto en
france24 punto com sigan junto a
nosotros
[Música]